there's a lot of talk out there that
Michael Cohen Trump's attorney or fixer
whatever you not call him that that he
that's that's what they're saying in the
papers they're called newspapers
[Applause]
considering Donnelly but there's a lot
of people in the poll that are saying
that Trump this is the word that he
doesn't treat his employees well that
he's not the nicest employer and that he
can be rough with people and that some
of this karma may come back to bite him
they're people saying that that Michael
Cohen might flip he might have things to
say and that one of the things that
might cause his loyalty to fray a little
bit is that Trump isn't nice to the
people that work for him have you heard
have you heard that listen we've
reported this out on multiple occasions
there were men that may not be popular
in American politics but who were very
loyal to Donald Trump men like Chris
Christie and Rudy Giuliani and Trump
sort of casual cruelty toward the people
who are loyal to him the fact that it's
a one-way street is sort of karma in a
time warp
I mean it's caught up with him in real
time and karma usually takes you know a
longer time to catch up with him but I
think for someone who has treated so
many people so badly it's catching up to
him and warp speed with all the
investigations and all that all the sort
of unfixed things that is fixed the only
thing about him I could say is he's just
so consistent I mean like he's
consistently says crazy stuff so he's
sensitized at this point the last one
that did kind of amuse me was when Joe
Biden said I if we were in high school I
beat you up and then Trump said I hit
you so hard you'd be crying all the way
down and that's kind of funny
you'd be crying all the way down I mean
who's talks like but at least he's
consistent right yeah has he said
anything just kind of an island no I'm
in the last he's consistently out there
it's consistently inconsistent yeah I
can agree on yes
things always should call him I wish we
had more time he's creepy you know I
wish we had more time but Dana's used it
up with his foolishness and I just can't
just restart this segment I'm I'm sorry
I'm a needy little clown well Dana I
wouldn't know anything about that
you